[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de América Latina
y el mundo el uso de programas de
Inteligencia artificial capaces de
generar imágenes a partir de
descripciones textuales Se dispara cada
vez más el resultado de estas
herramientas ha sido imágenes divertidas
y surrealistas algunas con una capacidad
de detalle tan sofisticada que ha
provocado confusiones entre los usuarios
de redes sociales quienes han tenido
dificultades para distinguir entre la
realidad y la ficción lo que genera
temores de que este tipo de sistemas
contribuyan a la desinformación en esta
emisión analizamos Porque empezamos
las fotografías del expresidente
estadounidense Donald Trump siendo
arrestado de manera dramática en las
calles de Nueva York y ante la mirada
desesperada de sus familiares se
viralizaron en internet y aunque esta
sería una escena anhelada por los
detractores del exmandatario Lo cierto
es que es producto del programa de
Inteligencia artificial mick Journey un
sistema que genera imágenes a partir de
la descripción que usted le plantee
estas Por ejemplo fueron los resultados
de una solicitud de eliothiggins
periodista y fundador del sitio web de
periodismo investigativo belling Cat
quien pidió al programa mid Journey que
diseñara cómo sería el arresto de Trump
su vida en la cárcel y su fuga
Aunque higgins reiteró que se trataba de
una broma en medios de comunicación como
bossfit news reportaron que algunos
usuarios de redes sociales llegaron a
creer en la autenticidad de estas
imágenes esto da cuenta de la facilidad
con la que la Inteligencia artificial
Puede crear contenidos capaces de
socavar la noción de la verdad Pero como
toda máquina también comete errores
veamos en esta fotografía están visibles
las dos imágenes o las dos manos tanto
del expresidente Donald Trump como del
oficial de policía pero parece sobrar
una mano que no se sabe de quién es en
la siguiente fotografía también parecen
salirle tres piernas del cuerpo del ex
presidente Donald Trump y en la última
fotografía aparecen dos rostros
completamente distorsionados
este tipo de modalidades no son nuevas
en 2018 el mundo se sorprendió al saber
que la Inteligencia artificial podía
usarse para crear deepfakes vídeos
manipulados de personas haciendo
diciendo cosas que nunca pasaron
previamente hablamos con Ana romualdo
experta en regulación de Inteligencia
artificial y tecnologías digitales quien
nos contó que aunque Este es un ejemplo
de cómo estas tecnologías se pueden
utilizar para otros fines no significa
que estén al servicio de la
desinformación
entiendo que la generación de imágenes
está todavía un paso más allá porque
entonces ya si tú generas algo como
podías generar algún tema en de
desinformación ahora ya lo puedes decir
y Aquí tengo las pruebas y aquí tengo la
imagen y aquí tengo el video entonces
entra ahí también un tema adicional en
el que tenemos que hablar de cómo se
educan las audiencias y la cultura que
existe en torno a la desinformación se
va a tomar lo que se lo que se vea a
pues no aquí lo que se tiene que hacer
también es que tengamos audiencias más
críticas y que miren las imágenes de un
de desde otra perspectiva por ejemplo en
lo que recientemente vimos de Trump
difícilmente creerían que Trump se va a
echar un Sprint no mirar detalles que
probablemente
a primera vista se pierdan pero se
tienen que analizar un poco más a
detalle para ver si sí o no lo mismo que
ocurre en el tema de desinformación ser
un poco más crítico ser un poco más
analíticos es cierto ahí el tema es que
nos deja Mucho peso sobre las audiencias
pero eso es ahorita lo que podemos hacer
pero a quién le corresponde regular Este
tipo de contenidos en quién recae la
responsabilidad y además cómo hacerlo
Ana rumundo nos explica Pues es que ahí
está sujeto a términos y condiciones una
cosa acuérdense que esto no es que
porque no exista una ley de no sé qué no
no hay una regulación Aquí hay una
autorregulación entonces de entrada son
los términos y condiciones así como no
se los propios términos y condiciones
prohíben la utilización de todo tipo de
softwares para temas de violencia para
temas
de criminales también para temas de
desinformación
pueden existir limitantes Pero esto no
significa que forzosamente Por eso te
decía que no es que la Inteligencia
artificial está el servicio de algo no
es que sea
autoejecutable eso sino que
no están No es tan fácil que se pueda
detectar y y detener sino que esto ya
está más bien hermanos de los de las
personas que utilizan esos sistemas la
responsabilidad recae en quien está
utilizando este tipo de Inteligencia
artificial generativa para crear esta
desinformación porque por ejemplo si tú
utilizas una computadora para generar un
texto de esa información no es que la
responsabilidad caiga sobre quien está
manufacturando la computadora o sobre el
desarrollador del Software con el que
escribes eso sino sobre ti como usuario
y es que la Inteligencia artificial
llegó para quedarse cada vez son más las
empresas que integran este tipo de
tecnología los productos que usamos a
diario y por ello nos corresponde no
solo seguirle El Paso sino hacerlo con
responsabilidad esto Dijo Ana romualto
la Inteligencia artificial viene para
cambiarnos la perspectiva de un montón
de cosas y para que entendamos Que es
una herramienta número uno o sea a pesar
que esto se ha repetido bastantes veces
es una herramienta no es un sustituto
entonces no es que
sentir o que se pueda comparar que pueda
ser comparable a las habilidades
cognitivas humanas o a la conciencia
humana absolutamente no Entonces primero
entender que es una herramienta luego y
que a mí me parece bastante importante
no ponernos en piloto automático sino
ponerlos en el asiento del conductor
aunque seamos usuarios esto puede
ocurrir en cosas tan sencillas y que ya
tienen tanto tiempo como cuando sigues
una ruta en tu navegador entonces
también tenemos que tener un humano en
el up que sea que toma la decisión final
y que ahí es donde radica la
responsabilidad del uso de estas
herramientas hasta aquí este capítulo de
revista digital recuerde que si quieres
repetir este u otro episodio lo puede
hacer A través de nuestra página web
triple W punto franz24.com
[Música]